[Music]
details coming in after a judge released
the fbi search warrant at the raid on
trump's home fbi just took 20 boxes of
items that included some marked as top
secret now there's a huge battle going
on whether trump declassified the
documents first take a listen to this
we don't know if the tssci material was
identified in the affidavit or simply
discovered in the course of of this
search
president trump had the ultimate
declassification authority but that
authority ended when he was no longer
president i'd be interested to know how
they are going to prove that it's
classified
i'm sure it was classified at one point
but you know we've never litigated this
before it's going to be a real question
of fact here about you know
whether president trump declassified it
or not when he still had the power
to do that
so greg i think the beef everybody has
with this is there's a hierarchy here
it's not hypocrisy it's a hierarchy for
the left you have a hillary clinton case
where remember when she said there was a
c on the document she played stupid and
she didn't know what it meant um
remember that she oh i didn't know what
the c what did it mean did you know it
mean clearwater florida like she had no
idea and yet trump would get a raid at
his house yeah and i i mean you know the
thing is
we should do a show just called we don't
know and just that way we don't have to
keep that way what we're doing that's
without thank you for telegraphing my
jokes oh sorry yes no but
we have to start everything with like we
don't know but what we do know is that
and this is a case where the double
standard what about ism works the
hillary server was far more sensitive
than this because it was real-time
communication on a server and a bathroom
from our secretary of state while she
was communicating with russia and then
somehow it ends up on anthony weiner's
laptop
among other things uh which then he used
to surf the web for god knows what that
somehow just kind of slid on by then you
got to you got to think about
afghanistan i don't know enough i don't
know but what about all that stuff left
behind in afghanistan was none of that
was some of that classified we left it
with our worst enemy and that isn't
trump jessica it's the taliban uh but
but the fact is i mean consider the tech
and all those helicopters right there
were documents there were computers
maybe a lot of it was destroyed maybe
some of it wasn't there was like seven
billion dollars worth of gear uh that we
do know that that pull-out we do know
this was not conducted well
so i really don't know how much
classified material was lost then so i
think that in this case
the what about ism is thoroughly valid
because it's the context that makes this
so laughable the 12 boxes of what is
related to something that might be
nuclear what does that mean was it a
note to kim jong-un saying hey had a
great time yeah you know dana when
people say to me that's what about ism i
say you're damn right it's what about it
i don't understand like how that's an
argument yeah right so i'm making a case
that the standards of so-called justice
apply to one party and not another and
your argument is yes that's correct and
you should just eat it like no i'm not
going to eat it i always would try to
imagine my
uh i don't know the hillary clinton
comparison is a good one i forgot about
when she didn't know what the letter c
meant
um but the sandy burger one for me uh
you're in the middle of the 911
commission you have the national
security advisor for the clintons go to
the archives do some research stuff some
documents in his pants and his socks
walk out and ends up with probation and
a fine
and
his health never raided now maybe
because he was cooperating i don't know
the other thing i think is i'm going to
make two other points
let's say it is a nuclear document first
of all well let me make two points i had
tops i had sci clearance you probably
did two right okay so
when you go to an sti briefing there's
not like paperwork passed out if there
is it's collected and everyone takes it
back
i don't know how you would even have
an sti document to put in a box i don't
understand that and also
if it is something to do with nuclear
stuff why would that be declassified
like what is it like is it the letter
that says hey that was like great time i
hope you don't
set off any more missiles yeah please
don't send me
don't do that little rocket man if you
don't do it i'll stop calling you that
exactly something like that like okay so
i can understand declassifying that that
would be fine but if it's something i
don't and here's the other thing we may
never know the last point i will make is
um
the presidential records act came in
after watergate
then we have this invention called email
and the internet that's right and
whereas you used to have maybe tens of
thousands of documents you now have
tens of millions of documents it's all
the emails it's everything that you ever
did while you were there all your text
messages now those are presidential
documents
and what andy was saying is that we've
never litigated this if a president
declassifies something on nuclear
weapons or or capabilities or resources
or locations
he could he can do that
but also there's a process that it's
never been tested in courts does the cia
director get a say do our allies going
to say anything like that
none of that has been tested yet which
is why we shouldn't have jumped the gun
but jess
the what about is an argument yes that's
correct it's absolutely what it about
isn't what i don't understand is how
people on the left democrats and
liberals don't see it through our eyes
like i can see your argument you don't
like that trump may have taken
classified documents fine we just
process for that i get it
how do you not see that hillary clinton
literally didn't even have an email with
the state department was unquestionably
emailing classified material
nothing has happened to her at all or
anyone you don't see how we'd be a
little annoyed that this is now a major
deal worthy of a raid it's like you
don't get that
i get it i've spent plenty of time with
people who share your world view and i'm
pretty seasoned in it at this point and
i'm good at saying
it's not going to be like this it's
going to be like this and and that's
important and we should all spend more
time talking to people who don't share
our own world view but i did miss the
part of american history where hillary
clinton was president of the united
states of america after she had you know
sent classified information on a private
server and went on to you know a
beautiful four-year term and whatever
else she lost the election because of an
fbi investigation 11 days before a
presidential election jim comey as the
head of the fbi came out and said that
they had reopened a year's long
investigation because there was new
information that ended up being a dud
and then he had to come out and he had
to say that and then he's had to eat you
know you know what for the last
six years because everybody hates him
because he did that because he violated
protocol coming out and commenting on an
ongoing fbi investigation which by the
way christopher wray a trump appointee
and merrick garland both did not do
until their hands were forced by donald
trump who was the one who said hey
mar-a-lago was rated this morning i want
to talk about it i want to talk about it
hillary clinton has been investigated by
the fbi by the senate republican
uh run senate committee who both found
that her server was never hacked by a
foreign entity and the f don't go um
i actually have a source on that so okay
well i have a source
every senate republican
but then why did senate republicans who
i would say on the list of things that
they hate have hillary clinton like way
up high not have said that out loud if
that's what they found so i i get it and
i when it happened i said that she
absolutely should not have been not
doing things by the book on this but
that they are not comparable and for you
to act like she won in any of this she
did not when she lost the biggest
election there is
and
i just i don't remember the search
warrant on hillary's house so i missed
that maybe because she
refused to comply yeah i got it the
department of justice treated hillary
clinton with
not just kid gloves
um they coddled her like a baby
and they interviewed her with her
attorneys president who were
co-conspirators long after the original
comey statement and her answers were so
ridiculous she should have been charged
with making false statements and a
reminder martha stewart went to prison
for five months for doing that very
thing there's only one thing that
matters in this what you got
give it to me
it better be
big
super-sized
like jupiter-sized information for you
to
crush
a standard that stood in this country
for more than two centuries more than
230 years and i just i understand that
the left democrats don't like trump but
i don't understand how you are more
upset about an fbi run by chris wray and
a justice department run by merrick
garland that defrauded and deceived all
american people with the russia
collusion fraud the dossier lying
repeatedly to spy on an american citizen
when the fisa court himself the chief
judge called out the fbi's
malfeasance that the
horowitz the inspector general at the
justice department called out the fbi's
malfeasance all merit girl you know what
put up or shut up you know if you found
something charge the president now he
could pull a jim comey he doesn't have
the authority to do it but technically
he does have the power to do it when
evidence seized is remains um sealed
until it's introduced as part of a
criminal proceeding but he could step up
and say
this what we got this is what we got on
trump that's all that matters in all of
this and they won't do it because again
they're looking for january 6th let me
let me just say that in closing saying
hillary clinton complied when they
literally smash blackberries with
hammers is really like laughable so i
just want to throw that in there they
hammers they smash them they smash them
with hammers that's not complying i'm
sure pretty sure that's not part of the
process up next the fbi's trump awards
out but where's joe biden the
president's silent and on vacation it's
very nice i went to brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now